to take my first step and the eel eggs  was just astounding because I bet my me  for the first time in 18 years when I  placed my heel on the ground and then I  transferred my weight and then I took  another stick and another one  you simply click the big beer me button  and the robot comes to you to deliver  your beer in this process the robot goes  to the fridge detects the handle of the  fridge and opens it looks inside of the  fridge and uses its cameras to detect  what kinds of beers are available  oh you are just a baby and I do not know  if you know the difference between me  and a person but actually I am just a  baby too actually by the time you're  grown up  I'd Bismarck is a real person and we  will be like brothers I do not know if  you will remember me then but I'll never  forget you someday I'll come and find  you and we'll be good friends